Nintendo's switch controllers are
straight-up expensive a pair of joy
Khan's is 80 bucks and the official pro
controller is 70 bucks but powera is
offering two different controllers at
less than half the price and a pretty
damn good we're gonna be doing a lot
more with the switch so stick the game
spot for all that good stuff
now onto these controllers power raise
accessories are officially licensed by
Nintendo as you see the zelda breath of
the wild additions sports a sweet black
and gold color scheme and you get the
hill Ian crest with the Triforce on top
the gold d-pad gold lettering on the
face buttons and Link pull in his bow on
the right handle the Super Mario edition
is a vibrant red with a mosaic of Mario
iconography you can see stars flowers
banana peels coins blocks it's cute I
think it's a real cute I think it's
hella cute another neat addition in the
package are swappable analogue caps they
pop out easily but stay perfectly in
place while you're using the controller
you can choose between concave or convex
style sticks or mix it up if you want to
get wild and the most intriguing part
about these controllers is that they're
only 30 bucks it's kind of a bargain
considering how expensive switch stuff
can be now you're probably wondering why
they're only 30 bucks and there's a
couple reasons to that these only work
through a wired connection so you get a
USB 2.0 cable it snaps right into this
top USB port right here is mini or micro
USB so you only have a USB 2.0 cable
which means you can only use the
controller when the switch is docked you
got the USB plug in man right there
there you go and since these only work
when wired you don't get the motion
controls of the Joye cons or the pro
controller but everything else about
these controllers makes them the most
cost-effective solution for a gamepad on
the switch so what makes these
controllers so good well let me tell you
about my time playing zelda breath of
the wild
I poured several hours into one of the
best games of this generation button
presses are on point and my aiming with
the bow felt incredibly smooth moving
around and placing objects with Magnus's
felt great as well I can't say enough
about how smooth the analog sticks are
they're effortless to use and consistent
in terms of resistance it's definitely a
huge improvement over using the Joye
cons
now the joy cons are neat and they
function well but as someone with big
hands I need something more substantial
like a gamepad I didn't have any issues
with comfort at any moment with these
because they share similar ganar the pro
controller these also feature the same
soft tactile shoulder buttons and short
throw triggers as the pro controller and
these are a lot lighter since they don't
have to carry a battery inside but this
can go either way
I like lightweight peripherals but some
might not like the holo feel from
holding these controllers lastly I got a
compliment the smooth texture of the
controller's actual body it's not as
grippy as the pro controller but they do
feel great to hold now I know we tend to
think that cheaper controllers means a
cheaper build but aside from the wired
limitations and the lack of motion
controls power ease controllers are the
best option when you factor in price and
if you don't mind being plugged in all
the time the Nintendo switch is probably
the most exciting system out there right
now and I've been spending more time
with it
it also means I'm gonna round out the
best accessories in a video for the near
future so stick the GameSpot for that
thanks for watching we'll see you soon